for people who are listening or watching
this well we can try explaining again
what we're doing we are in the late
stages of design for what was supposed
to be network packet recording but is um
is involving a few other things here so
let's let's jump into what we were
talking about okay so the issue is that
when you have something like audio or an
image or network packets there are
multiple things um that you might do and
this was imagined in this thing called
remote value which Kolo Barbieri was
some was working on although I don't
think much has been done on it recently
um and remote value the idea is that
these are things that are being
requested of something like a mobile
device um but there are different ways
that the request can happen there can be
something where you request to the
mobile device when submit is pressed the
mobile device you just get that value
like the value of a magnetometer reading
as a single instantaneous value another
thing that could happen is that as that
when you set up the request for the
value that a gauge comes up on your
phone or whatever it is or in your
notebook that shows you the current
fluctuating value of the magnetic field
let's say and then well that's more like
yeah and then
guess that at some moment you press
submit
um
whatever that current value was becomes
the value that is sent back as the
result in other cases the snapshot case
which is like image capture audio
capture where there is a real-time thing
that's going on
well actually it's like image capture
not quite like audio capture there's a
real-time thing that's going on and you
have a GUI that you are pressing so for
example if I do audio capture here that
doesn't work because we're in a version
where it doesn't work I suppose it is
working in in the head branch build yes
yes well it shoots really no wonderful
so there's a problem there yes
[Music]
something is very wrong there can you
check create the UID
you
you
that's spectacular many things would not
work with that not working
that is two days ago as build that's a
bit odd shall I try a more recent is
this more recent one let's try this one
cloud deployment creativity
okay well that there in this version it
is working so let's see that is the
version from the tenth so it started
failing on the 11th okay so let's try
audio capture here
okay so this is a typical we capture
something by the way that button being
gray is crazy
does anybody I mean I thought we were
agreeing to change that it's that color
did you get that yeah I'm taking that to
the sign okay did that happen already or
not okay
okay
all right so okay so what I wanted to
highlight okay so there's the notion of
a snapshot like this then there is the
notion of a recorder let's start and
stop up and see this is all rather
confused
then there's the notion of a history but
this shows up in multiple different
cases right
and Roger what you've got here so audio
record which apparently only works in
the external build except it didn't work
there either oh you've got to I've got
to give it a device so if I think I'll
say automatic that should work okay
okay so now what's happening it is it is
now recording yes
and so what do I now dudes and I say
okay I'll just stop for example of that
audio so yeah yeah
and now you can say audio of that audio
stream and that should give you the
result
Wow this is pretty wild so this audio
record function starts off
okay now if I say spectrogram of that or
something
okay how do I kill how do I can ask the
normal of that okay but that's not how
it's going to work right no this is this
is not for the next version so we are
focusing other things at the moment but
wait we missing but spectrogram has to
return something yes
functionality and what is the what I'm
seeing here spectrogram for 11.3 will
return this still yes exactly
okay um okay all right so I gosh this is
pretty funky what this does so audio
stop returns nothing it doesn't return
the audio stream and this audio stream
thing here
gosh can you walk me through this this
is this seems kind of weird
Carlo why don't you walk through it okay
so this is you introduce this to kind of
have an something that works similarly
to all your play which does a similar
thing so are you playing all your record
create a stream and set the state of the
stream to either recording or playing so
if I do that for 11 I could say what do
you play of 11 well no really
nine nine okay
yeah Wow and this is some other branch
in the prototype that is I guess
conflicting but it's not playing I don't
think you know I mean there's clearly
some mistake here okay normally you
should be playing this would be playing
now yes that's pretty wild so but it's
playing on a different thread right so
it's it's playing asynchronously yes the
idea is that everything here is
programmatic and a synchronous as to
have an alternative to the goo in the
case okay but we don't do that for
example with lists animate we don't have
a mechanism for doing this no this is so
this is some new mechanism Roger KS talk
about this is there any other place
where this mechanism is being used now
this is a this is this is one place
where you know for audio real-time
actually matters
I understand but I mean we could imagine
a similar thing for something like an
animation yeah I'm not saying we
shouldn't have that I'm just saying that
that's not what it does the thing that
was designed for version 6
can ask something yeah how does this
dovetail with scheduled tasks and also
good streams like as in files it's not
it's not a stream in that sense but it's
it's closer to a task actually so yes we
try to make this work with the task
framework it just seemed to
unnecessarily complicate the whole
business of just playing and stopping
and audio file and all the object mainly
because it's kind of complicated to get
a task object to work as synchronously
without launching a new camera which
seems a bit ridiculous just to play and
on your file
isn't that what like your LSAT mean just
all the stuff that you just process not
separate colonel yes so for morning I'm
not particularly familiar with the task
framework but from what I understand the
two options have session submit and
local submit we did we did go through
the exercise of trying to cast this room
design on top of that and you have to go
through a few stages of administration
through the task framework to get to
what you want yes for a casual user of
audio that seems like why do I have to
go through this administrative process
that the task people have no it doesn't
make sense but but what I'm concerned
about is this idea that there is an
asynchronous thing that's running here
and we have special I mean we clearly
have tasks stop and those kinds of
things
that's right to imagine audio play
returning a task object we looked at
that okay we went through that but it it
it has a society Karla we did the color
did that exercise we have one of one
such you know
I mean for example this would be an
example of something that returns what
did that just do
why didn't that return a task object
I'll try it'll I don't know what's on
the product ranch okay let me try the
most civilized area um it's tried in 11
to
you
you
yeah there we go so that is a that is a
task that's running in an external
thread that is not a wool from engine
thread
by making sense
yes it's a URL task right which I would
think was similar to your plane you know
audio playing tasks yes and and then we
have a huge collection of functions that
do things like stop the tasks pause the
tasks and so on
makes sense yep so
I'm trying to understand I mean if you
were to do I mean if if we were to have
some kind of audio because because we're
also talking for the network packet
recording stuff we're also talking about
an asynchronous version of that too and
it seems like what you're doing here
okay so you're returning an object um
what you're doing with audio record is
returning an object here that is the
audio stream as opposed to returning a
task object which you net they need to
extract an audio stream from so that the
the difference here is this initiating
something where
I think I'm correct Steven yeah but we
could potentially unify these things by
having
I mean ultimately you're just going to
say audio of this to actually get the
audio is that correct for audio record
yes
you
and for audio play what what are the
operations you all do or you played that
doesn't that is kind of a different
category because that doesn't generate
an audio that is created from an audio
okay so we don't have any functionality
to extract the audio from the audio
stream but that's an output audio stream
and this is an input audio stream yes
but they say the same thing they look
the same here this is something that
yeah initially they were different and
we merge them together but yes I agree
there is slightly problematic okay so
the other thing that will happen with
audio is that you will have the ability
to have infinite length audio which is
currently not tuned right how by having
it compute you know it's the generator
of some kind that's right you know and I
can write and you know you want to stop
those two eventually
and hopefully it worried that like
something as fundamental as a generator
gets like developed in isolation just
for audio when we have we are supposed
to have a bunch of meetings to design
that for everything which generates a
different kind of generator color
yes column I think so I mean it's
channeling sine waves and things it's
sleep is still like an infant list
well okay fair enough yeah you can ask
for a bit a few more the name of one of
those things audio generator
the current one
yeah this is not not really what we're
talking about this is not mental no but
this is not instrument no no this this
that's right what we're talking about
right okay all right fine okay
so look it seems to me I mean what would
make the most sense to me would be that
audio play at least when the first
approximation returns a task object that
you know can be stopped paused
everything you would normally do with a
task object now I admit that the name
task objects a little bit weird for play
and maybe there's a way to deal with
that but we'll let's worry about that in
a second but in terms of functionality
having something which is like at the
URL tasks here is you know very much the
right thing how the hell do you pass a
task object
you say a task stop I believe talked
citizen
now I admit that that doesn't seem you
know for audio um the um that's you know
a weird name by the way we have a
comment from the livestream I'm saying
what about if somebody didn't realize
the recording where they're synchronous
seems like there should be some UI
indication that the task is running
actually there is in the case of this
audio stream and that's what that
playing and stopped thing it's a dynamic
it's dynamically picking that up from
the from the state of the task and
similarly in a task object there is also
a dynamic indication except that I think
in a case like this there can't be
because it really doesn't know
well actually I'm not sure I think I
think when the task is over
I'm it's supposed to have a dynamic
indication in this task object
presentation okay so so just understand
I mean yes there's a Roger did that
answer your question but like tasks
suspend yeah we went through this
exercise it looks very clumsy you know
from an audio casual audio user okay
that's but you know everywhere we want
to build it to going forward which we
don't have now and we're gonna have to
work on machine learning projects next
so it will be a little bit you know it
will be you know post one iteration okay
but it doesn't mean that you know unless
tasks work really well which you know
anecdotally they do not that I think
they do now I think they do I mean they
after lots of effort I think they do but
but let's not let's not worry about that
let's just try to understand the
semantics of what we're trying to do so
one thing is audio play is basically
running an asynchronous task in a thread
that is a non Wolff mention thread true
audiorecord is has another special
feature so audio play what do you mean
that is a non wolfram engine thread
isn't there well I don't know is this
it's a separate it's there isn't a
Wolfram engine that is being run in that
thread is that correct for audio for
audio playing yes
I mean it's it's a subsystem of the
Wolfram engine but it doesn't you know
its evaluate of free if that's what
you're asking
that's what I'm asking yeah it's lu8 of
free okay fine
but audio record now is it somewhat
different story because it has the
feature that it has a couple of special
features so one feature is that it is
running in a separate thread
asynchronously right but
boy this is really funky I mean so
audiorecord has returned a handle when
run returns this audio stream handle
which has a GUI indicator of whether it
is in fact recording at that time but
then
so if it is recording at any given time
no I'm really confused at any given time
I can pick up that handle and I can say
audio of that and it will take that
stream and it'll give me the audio to
date in that stream is that correct so
yeah we need to iron out some things
there because I think default memory and
getting the data at the same time having
to file streams open at the same time
seems a bit tricky but ideally
especially if you take in memory around
there right but what do you think the
semantics are supposed to be so audio
resolves the current an audio stream and
then you know can I not extract the
audio from it until it is stopped or can
I extract the audio at any time you
should be able to extract the audio at
any time and moreover I would think you
should be able to write a piece of code
that extract the last five seconds of
audio at any time yes okay which is very
similar to the device framework where we
have things like device read latest
right
or device read I mean this is a
continuous stream version of something a
bit like this if I'm not mistaken
yes well in any case so so let's just
loop back to more of these things so
we've got a bunch of these sources of
continuous data so for example let's
let's just make a little list of these
things so we've got um and let me let me
save this away in the remote value in
the place where I've been saving
information about remote value
among the sources are things like so
we've got first of all sources we've got
audio recording we've got camera we've
got a network packet capture
we've got head devices we've got device
devices we've got things like Mouse
position
which is a hid device
yeah I mean that that's that's current
value values because that would be
things like plus other current values so
that's things like window position and
so on
did you find that please I have not yet
I think the interesting question is what
is the current value halogen its are
like a pressure don't expect them to be
employed values yeah okay
what are we calling this
[Music]
okay
okay so they're these things then there
are types of recording basically types
of value acquisition
so one one of those is instantaneous
value
okay and that would be things like
current image and mouse position that
right then we've got um
GUI
shot GUI basically
and that will be things like image
capture
right
then we've got I mean hopefully not
because image capture is reading your
East compared remember we were talking
about this with respect to controls in
which capture is prints the result
doesn't fit that you cannot bind it to a
dynamic variable so it's not very good
for uniforms and stuff of that for
manipulate
what do you mean I mean so image capture
has a GUI yeah open it and unless you
don't wanna show your face no I meant a
and just let me a.m.
it's just that it has a GUI and then
when you see it click record it just
prints the image no so it doesn't work
like a slider
ah see
put it on device
actually has--
that's a document camera okay there we
go ding-ding-ding-ding
okay so what do I do here I so so then
what happens I have to take the picture
here right
oh I see that's horrifying copy frame to
clipboard what is this weird thing stop
camera
okay capture frame two notebook
I see that's totally weird why doesn't
it work like a dynamic control like
slider
I mean that would be okay so that would
be does this work like a dynamic control
I guess we have the same problem with
disorder functionality that's being
designed but you it will be difficult to
used as a controller
well but that's a different question
from here I'm gonna delete this thing
here um people understand this thing
like I mean this is like it's like a
complete manipulate on its own if you
want to think about it that way
it's it's not like a component that you
use in a manipulate right regulate on
its own and how do you use another
manipulate inside another manipulate or
you can do that well that's not a
problem I mean there's the UX problem
and that's one thing but the other thing
is that's for example for all this stuff
light I mean it might be interesting to
design it you know design something that
is an actual control but but we've
separated it to you know yeah but you
slider is a control but manipulate is
not no I understand that but what I'm
saying is that we're talking so there
are you complicating things aren't you
the the thing we were talking about with
respect to client value was integration
say in the iOS app so might even be
modal but sometimes it's necessary okay
so you're asking for a controlled
version for what okay so let's there is
two sub cases here what what this is
that the conclusion here is that there's
a snapshot GUI and there are two sub
cases of a snapshot GUI one case is as a
control component and the other is as a
complete GUI is that correct which means
that and if
Carlo was asking about control
components is yes complete GUI and that
the way this operates is the way you get
a value is by quotes printing and in
this one the way you get a value is by
dynamic point is by a dynamic variable
right yeah exactly like okay that's not
that's not going with that because we've
got yet another case coming up okay
because the case of let's talk about
this one is instantaneous right snapshot
GUI instantaneous you know snapping
instantaneous values
and I'm making sense
I can't spell
instant taunts Wow I haven't heard about
those in a long time um okay so the next
case is a essentially a time series
capture GUI
and that's things like audio capture
well I would say temporal fine
you know temporal capturing GUI there
was the another case which was similar
to dynamic binding but the other way
around which was like a gauge so you
wanna have a gauge of the testable
volume in the room you're in we're not
recording anything that's dynamic of
something
okay right right right so that's the
installation value so well that's a
gauge where it doesn't do anything but
that's really like the it's like the
snapshot GUI where you're just showing
the gauge part of the snapshot GUI but
do you mean something else so we have
something that's formerly called gauges
or their dos what you guys are talking
about well they could if it was a scale
of value yes but but it could just be
like we have an image capture where they
say where there's a real time display
right snapping instantaneous values but
okay displaying a real time preview
you
you
then snapping instantaneous values that
make sense
that case and I think remember I think I
sent you at some point like a prototype
of how all these things could be built
with the current image so dynamic of
current image is just a page of the
webcam then you can build one where you
can freeze them and bind to dynamic each
time you want part of why it's there I
guess that's my current yeah right yeah
I mean it's value right but the question
is that Carlo is making the claim which
I don't entirely believe that everything
else can be built just from having a
instantaneous value for example I don't
know you could have an instantaneous
value it's the displacement of the
microphone but it's a little weird but
let's keep going please we've got what's
that yeah good luck with that
yeah right right and the software radio
it's even more insane we've got a
gigahertz we've got you know electrons
moving at a gigahertz um okay so
look and we are we've run really
overtime here but but we let this just
continue for a moment about on this um
and
you
someone from our lives
I'll paste their comment in here
the lovely things about these live
streams is that they are largely
anonymous because we have no idea who
these various handles are but this is a
comment
you
it's kind of true
um
okay let's keep going here though okay
we've got a cap chiral tempering do it
Tec temporal capturing GUI
and then we have programmatic
you
temporal capturing
sons
which right now we think of as a
different function so the temporal
capturing GUI would be something like
network packet capture
you
and here our programmatic temporal
capturing would be network packet
recording right now it's device read
time series the same yes this is device
read time series okay now we don't have
four devices we don't have this temporal
capturing GUI we could
we perfectly well could
um for head devices we have what do we
have for her devices we have controller
state I don't think we have anything
except for instantaneous right so there
we have okay so
you
okay um
or current value within that same genre
it is right okay so we've got these ones
all just returned okay so where is audio
record in this whole picture it is
okay so then we've got what we might
call okay so this is quotes fire okay
there are two cases of this the fire and
forget case
the fire and forget but the fire and
forget synchronous well actually we
could call this the blocking blocking
case
also it's also fire-and-forget as in you
start it and there's nothing you can do
about it
maybe maybe puts up a GUI where you can
do something about it but then there is
the the non-blocking case
actually this isn't even correct I mean
what is audio record where does it fit
into this ontology into the non-blocking
case of this yes can you give it a time
to record for yes say with an option
okay but that's already humph are you
sure it fits into this case because I
think of this case as okay so so it's
definitely it's definitely programmatic
temporal capturing yes and it is
definitely non blocking okay well so in
that case audio record the way that's
working is it is bringing back a thing
whose value is going to be the result so
these things here these things here all
simply return accumulated stuff right
the the time series effectively I'm
going to put time series and quotes
whereas this case does not return the
time series it returns
a handle to the accumulating
to
well it returns a handle to the
accumulator or so to speak right yes and
then there's a separate step so then and
then this non-blocking case also
supports you know pause stop functions
does it simple those are right yes
correct so you can continue accumulating
right exactly whereas in these cases
it's like one time but it has the nice
feature in this case that it simply
returns the goods so to speak it returns
the thing you were trying to compute
okay so with this with this outline
let's just take a look at what are
different things and then okay we've got
another case actually we've got another
case here we've got another non-blocking
case this is non-blocking
um okay another non-blocking case is the
non-blocking callback case
you
okay which is analogous to do we have a
device submit I can't remember no we do
not
it's device excuse
oh well we got to change that it's
aren't eager to do
whose whose budget managing that
out whose budget managing that please
okay there is also the the temporal
capturing GUI just as a control
thank you he lifted that above no that's
instantaneous like there's four of them
temporal instantaneous and okay hold on
I don't understand consider the
non-blocking case for a second here so
the way this works it has a callback
function you know has a callback when
the data has been captured
or or eg when an event is seen in the
data right as opposed to this case where
you pick up the handle there's a little
bit weird I mean these are two cases
because in this case this is returning a
task object
okay which is merely a controlling the
the asynchronous process it's not a
thing where you can just well actually
can you can go ask the task object what
expression did you get as your results
so you can do the same thing as asking
for audio of the audio stream
I'm making sense
we've already got that kind of
functionality for a task object
but this also provides the capability of
having a handler function which does a
callback
and this also supports pause and stop so
I mean really this this non-block this
case I really think is covered in this
case although not in the UI that you've
developed here
okay go ahead I was just gonna say I
want I think one thing that would make
it much easier to work with these task
objects is if there is a concept of like
sending a general you know kind of like
poking the task object with the general
event right so you'd have you be able to
submit some kind of event to the task
like audio pause or audio stock right
then it makes a little bit more sense
you get the task object and somehow send
an event of pause or stop or something
and then it looks it reads a little bit
better than running tasks suspend or
tasks resume or something well that's
true and the other point is that the
task objects GUI could perfectly well
sport certain buttons that do that which
is what you're doing here with with
audio stream right
you have both okay so in this case in
this case the accumulator has a visible
you know manifestation that contains
controls no those are not controls just
indicators oh so you can't stop it
no because filled out you would use the
GUI case I guess the idea is with these
the control is purely programmatic why
do you think that the GUI case shouldn't
be stoppable with audio stop
the wrong thing that's the problem
because it isn't the GUI case actually
isn't returning yeah it's an object or
its own and everything that's not
running outside but that's the real case
that's the real thing I think but we
could imagine in these blobs here I
think we could imagine having controls
here having GUI controls here that is
you generate this thing and it also has
a programmatic control that can be done
asynchronously but if you're looking
right at it you probably could just
press a button in it
like exams sure but I it seems like it
ends up in a bit of a duplication of
functionality given that there is
another GUI overly access from that
maybe ok so that's a possible thing
ok now let's listen to Carlos point
about his four cases and what we maybe
have not captured here
now you have a stretch snapshot booyah
Stu subcomponents and I think the
temporal capturing we should have to do
subcomponents control the complete what
is audio can understand how would or do
capture be a control
well it's model just like the way
filename scepter works
okay let's remind ourselves how that
works all right
it doesn't need to be mobile because you
can just okay we file them chatter so
you're saying file names that are of
dynamic lakhs
you
okay and then if only we can go back
somewhere else
you
Oh some some random
and I'd pick a file and
okay so what's your point my point is
that you see that that's something that
has to block somehow just like a the
audio recorder but they'll deliver it
doesn't need to block could have a
button that says start recording then
you stop recording and then it binds at
the end when you click OK it binds I see
I see I see I see I see I see okay so
this is communicating value
yeah okay by binding communicating value
by binding a variable
and so your point here this is whoops
this is communicating value by the
return from the function right yeah and
I mean my my design strategy for forms
is that it's very easy to build the
second from the first not so much
okay so communicating value by blinding
a variable
okay I mean there could be
you
and why isn't that something like
I'm not sure um
a function that does that okay you just
let's say that we have this thing that
we call audio recording it's
programmatic fire forget and eventually
a value gets assigned
okay if you make that that value you
know you get a variable to be that can't
you make that dynamic and do what you
want hold on hold on you're saying audio
recording is a blocking or a non
blocking case it's blocking it's
blocking it returns a value eventually
you know and an audio object and if you
said X equal to that can't you make that
X be your dynamic thing that you I would
think so you need to say - what if you
wanted non-blocking
like if you have it alongside a slider
or something like that
but when I'm not sure what that would
mean though given when would you
when would you sort of well here's an
example where you want the non-blocking
case so let's say you're doing an image
capture but you want X to be continually
set to dynamic you know I mean look you
know there's a simple case I mean I just
say if I say something like um dynamic
what do I want to do here I want to say
dynamic of y equals current image can I
do that and then I say dynamic of edge
detect of Y okay now I go and do this
and everything is cool right but but you
sort of need to accumulate something up
if you look look at that stealing can
you pull up the documentation for film
control look at the first example
you
you
this thing here yeah so basic basically
in that thing you have to click Submit
to bind and you can type continuously
and it doesn't affect so in this is kind
of like accumulating things in this case
it's doing wantedly so it's talking to
alpha so it's not really something we
can do in real time as you type so hold
on hold on hold on this is the case
where you're saying this is a GUI that
is giving you a preview in real time
I'm a making sense but um
let's see it's a preview in real time
and then it has a button that says
give the value is that what you're
saying oh I don't know some yeah that's
what I'm saying and I'm saying that this
type of us can work also when you have
to accumulate
why how I don't understand if there's a
single button how does that deal with it
because how far is it accumulated oh you
would have you would have two buttons
you would have a button for recording
stop and other for submit and it's only
when you click Submit that you bind
I see so that's different from
well wait a minute audio capture has
let's just understand what that's doing
so audio capture has a button oops
what is it submit button
button that's the pause button and the
stop is the submit button so I mean that
has exactly that audio CAPTCHA has
exactly that functionality right
so audio capture that um it has a start
pause stop + submit right
Carlos does that make sense yeah it
doesn't make sense but it doesn't by its
return but yes I understand it how would
you okay
don't we have a generic way of doing
that binding by basically just saying
dynamic of x equals that that depends on
whether it's blocky or not
oh I see I see I see by binding a
variable in real time but what is it
bound to is it bound to the stream so
far or what Oh
so you click record did you record five
seconds then you take stop no no I
understand but oh it only binds what's
the point of that why not just say
dynamic of X equals that because then
you can use it in the late forms so can
you hear I just did that here
you not it's not quite you cannot do
that you cannot put that as a control in
a manipulate you have explicity is
another variable is dynamic another when
you start dealing with the Association
in the form object blah blah blahs
forcing further validation alright this
is the case we don't fully understand I
mean this is this is question mark
question mark this is Carlos case um
okay but let's go back to what we were
trying to solve right now okay which we
need to get straightened out so
I don't think you know look we're not
going to change this for this version
for this version we're gonna have an
experimental audio record function and
it will return an audio stream but I
don't think that's ultimately the right
thing I think I mean the whole point is
we need these generic you know these
generic functions pause stop etc etc etc
which we have got for the task framework
although they have names that involve
the word tasks am i making sense
yeah
I mean I don't think it's unreasonable
to add either a new task function like
task signal or task interrupt or task
event or so maybe even it's a something
that you can call as a property of the
task object so that you can have custom
you know names for these like that
aren't specific to tasks right right but
I also think that even in this case when
you return a visible accumulator the
accumulator could sport buttons
and look this whole question about
whether tasks stop is too confusing when
you saying audio record an audio record
returns a task object once it's returned
a task object is not so obscure to say
tasks stop
but in any case that that's that will be
my suggestion for how to do that
although I agree that there may be some
dressing that can be provided there that
will help it um
let me get rid of my dynamics my X&Y as
dynamic variables I suspect that's going
to cause trouble um okay so okay so now
the next issue is in the blocking case
right there are many criteria the thing
we were coming to is there are different
criteria so first of all
you
these cases are not consistent with the
image capture case which does this weird
printing thing
why does image capture not simply have
so image capture base basically can um
okay image capture is like kind of a
stem cell or something I know that's the
wrong way to put it it's a it's a it
kind of stays and it spawns other things
whereas audio capture just says okay I'm
done and returns right so that's the
difference here which is um
so this the control stays the the object
stays um but basically prints results so
that's really only useful image capture
is not programmatically useful there's
audio capture programmatically useful
yeah how it's modal you do your thing
and when it returns you get the audio
object no I understand that but but so
what you could say what you cannot do
with image capture what I could do is I
could put in a piece of code I could say
you know if audio capture of blah you
know if some audio processing of audio
capture if I said boo then do another
audio capture see what I'm saying
no no but that's why but that will work
right if if if the first audio capture
it will bring up what does it do if I
say that if I say what what the heck
does that do if I say
if I say table of audio capture
well no worst cases I say due to audio
capture - what did that do why is why is
there an audio capture showing on the
screen
we try running that audio capture
ooh I got another one and then I run
that one and boom nothing comes back so
those are just they just found it table
if you did table it would come back
right well who does not return anything
does it no I understand that but I'm now
a totally confused okay so let's look at
this so this is this is as a side effect
it is bringing up the GUI
right it is like the input function if
I'm if I'm making sense right so this
audio can yeah brings up the GUI as a
side effect
you
meaning that evaluation can't finish
until you're finished
right but I mean this is like me saying
table of input yes too
you
like a modal dialog box right
okay
now why does image capture not work that
way
because it's useful in the case of image
capture it might be useful to generate
multiple pictures I mean as a practical
matter what one wants here um
this is quite a grotesque interface in
some ways okay let's put it at my
document camera okay so what I'm doing
here is I take one picture oh where did
that happen
well who knows but but basically this is
now printing which is really really
weird
I mean that's very analogous to if I do
manipulate X X 0 1 and I go here and I
say paste snapshot move it
paste snapshot right that's gonna do
what oh wow that's really funky did you
see what that's doing
yeah it's it's printing the the most
recent first that's really weird is that
what image capture does to
I have to get image capture actually
work somewhere um let's try it again
here and I'll set what you modeled it on
when you did it originally which image
capture
no no that was not that was not what was
thought about there okay so there I get
one thing let me move my my pen there
and then I press it again okay so that's
in fact that is what it's doing so it is
the most recent image is going is being
printed first
so it is like this the paced snapshot
you
you
um
ugh
okay um all right let's just look what
we've got to do right now so we clearly
need to discuss this further because
this is kind of a mess um but partly
because we're dealing with things I mean
we had talked about extensively before
the concept of something like a
magnetometer same with a mouse which has
a both an instantaneous value and a
history so for example what we don't
have here is any notion you know like
for our mouse position here we could
imagine a generic function okay so let's
consider design here um so there are
cases where the only thing that makes
sense is to capture a history like for
sound the instantaneous value of your
microphone is you know more or less
useless not a hundred percent useless I
have to say it's a pressure sensor sure
okay but but you know but for broad use
cases it's you know okay let's consider
the following thing how would we do
something like this do we have any way
to do this right now
record
you know let's say let's let's imagine
we want to say record time series and we
want to say mouse position and then we
want to say roughly TDT
right do we have a similar thing for
device read so if we look at device read
time series
yeah we've got the same TDT structure so
in a sense device read time series could
in principle read I mean it isn't
I mean we could have a function read
time series or something or well record
times this device treats hid devices as
actual devices
I do not know in principle it could I
mean certainly could open the head
device right let's try it I mean we've
got what is the how did we get that list
of her devices system information it's
nothing there's probably more direct way
but system information would certainly
list it well controller yeah controller
state lists the state of all hid devices
he says
device type mac os/x
what that is mac os/x interface device
let's try seeing what happens if I just
feed that in there
I think controller information
I think it said that the product name
was a screen also what the heck is that
look at that now I've got an audio
device sitting there
um I don't even understand that because
I've got many audio devices on this um
look at that what on earth are those
that's another can of worms right is the
hid controls for those devices
I'm saying yeah hmm which actually for
sound is not completely silly because
you might easily have that on a
microphone or on a keyboard
yes
that's correct okay so let's just look
in system information here
devices
where is my keyboard
oh you know what maybe my keyboard is
connected to my
no where's my keyboard
no idea I mean usually I thought the
keyboard was listed here
you
yeah I don't think and what's even more
bizarre is that I think I have many more
you know I've got a giant list of audio
devices in fact you can see that
something is fishy here
because I look at my audio output
devices list I've got multiple audio
output devices
but if we don't me only one with buttons
that communicate with the machine
maybe but what I'm surprised as my
keyboard isn't here I'm using Windows
here and I also don't see my keyboard I
recall in the past having seen that yeah
I thought so too
umm I mean we have the notion of current
value of a keyboard event oh no I
okay I have it it's just listed very
weird I have this wireless keyboard and
it lists it's on the death rather than
as a keyboard
okay but so here for example this
bizarre thing
okay so current value of shift key if I
say dynamic
oops
if I say dynamic of that then that will
tell me whether I'm pressing my shift
key so that's been routed to current
value there but okay be this as it may
what were you asking you were asking
whether whether you can read from the
mouse device well since I can't find the
mouse device sir i vas can't read from
it but but it would be reasonable
um you know in principle one could have
a current value time series
where I could say mouse position or
something like this and then I would say
TDT
yeah
and that would be a programmatic
recording of the current value
um as opposed to something where I bring
up you know where I could also have a
current value capture which brings up so
that one there is a programmatic
recording programmatic blocking
recording
you
does that even work I mean okay wait so
there's that this swimming depth that
you could write at yourself now probably
in two lines right
you
presumably accept as the code runs yeah
yeah yeah yes you could yes
okay current value capture would bring
up a GUI to start/stop
accumulating the time series
but now the question in this case in
that first case it's very obvious what
it returns current value time series
simply returns the time series
right in this case it's much less
obvious what it returns in that case it
can either be a printer like image
capture or
thing else
now notice that or like audio capture
where it is you know when it's done
it returns
what's the trade-off between things
where when it's done it returns versus
print it
I mean these things which are
fundamentally temporal I think that the
ones that we looked at you know it
doesn't seem totally wrong what they do
their image capture case no not on that
not on their own but and the reason for
that is images are instantaneous and so
it makes sense to snap many of them
audio it's a little weird you know you
could imagine saying I mean like you
could imagine snapping multiple
three-second audio things but that's
more obscure yeah
so I mean that means that capture so
similarly you know like screen capture
for example right so that is doing
that's another one you should have had
there on the list right yeah
what happened
what isn't that um
what does it know Canard lecture
is what it is it's current that's what
it is it's a current screen image
okay there that's the current screen
image see what I'm saying
so that's a current imaged guy
that's like current image and I'm making
sense so that's another example up there
of an instantaneous one
you
in fact directly analogous to current
image
analogous to instantaneous value there
is device Reid is also an instantaneous
value
makes sense
yeah the other thing and one thing that
you have to deal with when you're when
you're starting to go at fast data rates
and that's same food instrument control
they can't usually because I view our
device framework primarily sort of the
slower stuff so which is instrument
control rather than sort of the detailed
processing yeah you know but once you
start going faster what you typically
want and does make sense is to get sort
of chunks you know not at the same rate
but you get them sort of accumulated up
in certain chunks and that's accept a
device read buffer yeah
okay fine that's exactly how the audio
framework works underneath well okay so
so instantaneous value there's a sub
case of this which is okay so so there
is another case here which is um
instantaneous value
of a trailing time series of which
device read buffer is an example
I think that's trailing as opposed to a
prospective forward-looking
I'll pound device read the contents wits
Papa yeah yeah I don't think it blocks
does it
blocking function
okay I'm wrong well okay but but then
it's buffering so that is a blocking
function this case here is a blocking
function we discussed I think having a
non blocking version of this that just
reads whatever was in the bluff buffer
so that reads the historic no that reads
the future buffer am I making sense as
opposed to reading the what's in there
before buffer yeah so in a way there is
a notion of an event that says I'm ready
to buffer is full
yes that's correct
in fact it has a specific criterion for
buffer for completion
yeah okay so let's come back listen the
thing we have to solve right now I mean
we need to come back to all of this but
then we have to solve right this moment
is the network packet capture issue so
audio record I don't think we're going
to be able to change at this late stage
anyway my suggestion for the network
packet capture thing is the following
okay I was suggesting
actually it wasn't that packet capture
it was Network packet recording but we
haven't really got what is our generic
form for recording something I mean it
actually would be network packet time
series except that we don't happen to be
returning time series nor should we
okay actually I would like to yeah okay
okay
could be an explicit time series and
some of them or could be a sequence of
values a sequence of event like values
right so
more like I mean we could return we
could make network packet recording
return event series although I think
it'd be kind of silly is is he and still
with us unfortunately not he had to drop
okay
that's unfortunate since he's the main
one who is working on this but let me
let me go through this design for a
second because I had a proposed design
and at least we can um so my proposed
design was to say
you
Network packet recording of and then the
the simple case we just tea
you
see that this was the Scot that can you
um did somebody that the male that I
sent out yesterday um you had an
association no I I remember um okay
because this also has ports and services
and so on but the the general case that
I was proposing was network packet
recording of an association that could
contain like duration if that's what
we're calling it
expression which is an expression to be
evaluated during the thing count
or packets
possibly we could general
that two-count etc and then all the
various features of what the port is etc
so the idea there will be you could
specify you know whichever of those
things you want and it will keep going I
we have to decide what it does is you
specify multiple things
actually an alternative would be
to avoid okay so network packet
recording of n could record just n
packets of a quantity could record for
that time
you
you
but we could also have something where
we say things like this where we support
something like that where we basically
are specifying a naked element of the
Association if we wanted to
or full association
on this or is this not really the right
set of people for this so I think that
what you want to set up is various
things to can say you know record under
these circumstances or return it a
result
you know but most isn't them many
packets only this type of packets and I
have sorry didn't I have a section here
on network packets no but the last time
you saved it in core software
engineering
you
you
yes
we are reviewing that I mean that was
like right there
it's right there the issue that we were
dealing with is there are two cases that
were not covered here one is that you
want the recording to happen during the
evaluation of this expression okay so a
typical example that would be URL
executed whatever I want to know when I
go to that website
what weird packets get sent back and
forth or well I do this thing what
actually happens see what I'm saying
like for example the URL execute will be
a really good way to do testing of a
website because it'll get you back I
mean it in that particular case you know
you might actually like a time series
back and that that's a question which in
would would be the one to answer whether
we should be returning an event series
from Network packet recording
because you know network packet capture
to remind you guys if we do
you
packing recording
yes
you
you
you could you could do it you could do
it you know whichever one finishes first
you exit
the greatest idea to do that but that's
I mean that is the issue right is so
what happened here so you know
let's talk about returning this as an
Arab Series does it make sense or is it
just silly I think it's kind of just
silly silly
yeah cuz most of the time you just want
to know what were the packets and then
one of the facts about the packet as
well as the packets sent but that's
certainly not the only fact that you
want to know about the packet yeah you
might want to do sort of and that's not
time or events here it doesn't support
it but with but some you know okay this
is leads totally into another thing but
one important thing which comes up in
spatial which is that you look at the
relations between these time points
which are events yep
no and that's same for for points in
space you look at you know like trees or
they're related to each other
yep and that's much more interesting to
do in in many cases and that's really
what's makes sense but that's not how
well it's like a like a male you know
like threading in a male sequence yeah
but there are different kinds of you
know there's statistical kinds of things
that you can say about that like they
should be you know if it's a cue thing
like many computer systems are then you
know there's gonna have something that
looks like an exponential distribution
typically yes but I mean but what you're
saying is that through these packets
there are ones that are like my zoom
packets bouncing back and forth that are
related to each other like an email
thread would be related even though
there is a sequence to email like this
there is a sequence right see again
email is another case where the sequence
is probably the most important in this
specific time of whether it arrived at
3:22 or 3:23 p.m. is not really that
important okay let's return to this
though because what we're trying to do
the criteria are a certain number of
packets an amount of time I kind of
think the amount of time should be the
default because I think it's the most
useful but it's a little bit silly
because you know we have units and so we
could you know disambiguate that with
units versus herb versus an integer um
but we've got
it count we've got
uhh
we've got duration expression we've then
got various kinds of filters like
a little bit different I mean that's not
these are the descriptors of how long to
record for then here
we're recording what service are we
recording on etc Tara you know is it
HTTP and what's the IP address and so on
right so that's being specified there as
an association which is a filtering
Association
six
behind me I kind of think that may not
be quite the right group you know and
doesn't shouldn't even be part of it -
yes yes yes yes I mean the two things
are how long and what how long to record
and what to record
those are the two things we want to
specify
and interestingly if we look at device
read time series
okay it's very much now
got a T DT and then pram
pretty much the same story as here
well how long is in the middle how long
and resolution is in the middle well no
because got a device at the beginning
well the device is just the banks which
of what the heck you're talking about
but it's what you record right no
because this is saying record well the
device what you record right and then
the parameters so they know what your
the parameters are like are you
recording
I think the parameters are parameters of
the device that is exactly so so what is
device plus Pratt you know you don't
want to record everything it's some
parameters in the device that's correct
like let's you don't receive these plus
parameters
that is true except that the network
interface I mean network packet
recording generically is listening to
all network traffic and so what we're
doing here is simply to filter the
network traffic right okay um well so
I'm afraid we're going to have to
iterate with but does anybody else have
opinions about this I mean this is just
a messy design thing because
particularly this thing that goes across
an expression that's a new thing the
only thing I can think of that is
analogous to this is absolute timing and
I'm saying or we don't even have a
memory used thing but in other words
what happened to your machine you know
we could imagine something where you
know we could imagine something where
for example we could imagine a thing
that says you know machine power used or
something
during a computation there could be like
absolute time and this is this is yes we
do right but I mean this is something a
little bit like that except it's not
quite the same because this is all
network activity somebody is making back
on my spoiler um
yeah I know that but the problem with
this is that the packets don't
necessarily have anything to do with
that expression being evaluated they
could be a random ping packet that
arrived from you know the other side of
your network see what I'm saying but
during the period of an expression
evaluation it is looking at all network
traffic
right
- network traffic attributable to this
expression evaluation
make sense so it's a little bit of a
weird and different thing it's a little
bit of an approximate thing it's kind of
a
which would mean both a useful
absolutely but the point that I'm making
is if you say trace of a particular
expression everything that is in that
trace output was the result of
evaluating that expression it's not like
if you have an asynchronous task running
at the same time trace doesn't say oh
and by the way this computation was done
at the same time in the a synchronous
task
so I'm saying
whereas network packet recording what's
that
it's absolutely the case it's a it's a
recursive thing going through the
evaluator it has nothing to do with
other random junk that happens to be
happening in pre-emptive kernels and
things like this
so I mean anybody got any thoughts about
the way to handle this I mean
it seems to me that what we should do
that this is the least crazy way that
I've seen to do it that well maybe we
should do it like this where you give
where you can have when the first
argument is a is something of the form a
thing and then amount
you
and the default
would be perhaps account of the number
of packets
people
I mean look one way we could do this
you
we could say Network packet recording of
n is packet count
you
of
of quantity
you
or at least a time quantity is
[Music]
is time and we could do function is
expression
with that just being evaluated or we
could do something like hold here
I think that's rather grotesque I don't
like that anybody got comments on these
nope okay then let's wait and and we'll
have to pick this up again at the end
perhaps late today or or tomorrow okay
yes I do okay and then we need to
separately loop back and finish this
discussion of how to deal with all these
different cases um
yeah I mean this is a complement value
time series for mouse position time
series makes sense but for other things
you just don't care about the time about
the times that much you just care what
happened um all right anything else guys
oh okay see y'all soon